from food on the shelves
to a cheap energy deal
and now fuel at the pumps we're being
told it might get harder to get all
sorts of things at the moment
this is not a scene any supplier would
want closure when customers still want
to come there's now such a shortage of
hgv drivers bps having to ration fuel to
the forecourt a crisis is biting and
it's one of logistics
in a statement the company confirmed
we're experiencing fuel supply issues at
some of our retail sites in the uk and
unfortunately have therefore seen a
handful of sites temporarily close due
to a lack of both unleaded and diesel
grades
many pumps will be filled from terminals
like this but the fuel itself is not
short
enclosures will not be widespread in the
tens not in the hundreds the industry
rushing to reassure there's no reason to
panic buy there's no
outs in terms of
widespread stock outs if you if you
don't get a fuel a particular service
station of your choice you can always
drive to another one and you'll get
you'll get refueled
panic buying would be much more of a
problem but so far there's no sign of
that being widespread i have to use my
car to go to work
so if i don't have a car
i don't have a job are you filling up
because you're worried about a fuel
shortage or just yeah
neighbours just told us now the petrol
stations that are closed probably won't
stay that way for very long they're
being prioritized for refueling this one
for example told me they expect another
delivery before the day is out but it
does bring this lorry driver shortage
into critical focus it's a shortage
that's being caused partly by the
pandemic and a huge backlog in tests
partly by brexit with migrant workers
going home and partly because there
aren't enough younger workers coming up
who find the industry attractive
the industry needs another
000 drivers
and it's being felt by people like steve
he runs an hdv firm and this was him in
july
he's now down over 20 percent on the
staff he needs if things were bad then
they're now atrocious the situation is
grim very very grim and it's getting
worse they're going to get to a point
when they're going to have to say enough
we can't afford to move those goods
and the impacts being felt across the
economy everything from farms and food
to furniture and fittings many warn of a
breaking point and say action is needed
now in the short term we are asking
government to temporarily allow trained
safe professional european drivers into
the uk
to take up some of the vacant jobs
that will tide us over until we think
spring next year the government says
it's working hard to resolve this but
goods are not flowing as they should in
this country fuel just the latest
example but it certainly won't be the
last helen smith sky news